exceptionnel en france une
reconstitution privée organisée sur les
lieux d'un crime par les avocats du
condamné il s'agit du double meurtre de
montigny les metz en moselle
deux jeunes garçons tués à coups de
pierres en 1986 et patrick dils 16 ans à
l'époque a été condamné à la réclusion
criminelle à perpétuité en 89 il clame
son innocence et avocat cet après midi
ont annoncé la présence d'un nouveau
témoin pour cette reconstitution privée
fanny au vernis l'avocat de patrick dils
s'impatiente
il mène lui-même l'enquète et organise
cet après midi sa propre constitution
cette reconstitution va permettre
notamment de pointe et toutes les
incohérences du dossier
comme par exemple erreur capitale
cracovie patrick dills lors de la
reconstitution qu'il avait fait et que
l'instruction puisque notamment il s'est
trompé de plus de 40 mètres lorsqu'il a
désigné la situation des corps des deux
enfants par rapport à la vraie position
ils ont été relevés par la police alors
qu'il est essentiel d'avoir exécuté une
reconstitution privée ici à
montigny-lès-metz le long d'une voie
ferrée
là où le 26 septembre 1986 alexandre et
cyril ou 8 ans sont retrouvés morts
lapider patrick dils un jeune voisin
alors âgé de 16 ans avoue puis se
rétracte en 1989 il est condamné à la
réclusion criminelle à perpétuité
mais en 1997 un nouvel élément vient
relancer la sphère la présence avérée de
francis heaulme tueur aux séries sur les
lieux le jour du crime
la cour de révision est saisi et ange en
2000 ordonne un supplément donc est
mais pour l'avocat la justice ne va pas
assez vite
je souhaite de tout coeur que la cour de
révision comprennent qu'il faut hâter le
pas et que l'on ne peut pas encore
indéfiniment les saints innocents qui a
déjà purgé 14 ans de prison s'ils ont
tout état de cause est beaucoup trop des
mois et des mois en attendant un énième
supplément d'information la
reconstitution d'aujourd'hui est privée
et n'a aucune valeur juridique mais
l'avocat de patrick dils espère la
présence d'un nouveau témoin